hello everyone welcome to Pi data day
one
um for this next presentation we have
Kevin Koh and Anthony Holton Kevin is a
maintainer at the fuke project and and
Anthony is a senior software engineer at
interos
in this session Kevin and Anthony will
be showing us how to Port existing code
to a distributed back end using Fugue
with minimal rewrites so give it up for
Kevin and Anthony
uh test
uh can you hear me okay
don't oh thank you okay so um just some
logistic things first uh before we get
to the the tutorial uh we uh asked
notable to so our demo will be unnotable
which is an Enterprise grade uh notebook
platform and we asked them to
um bump up the default number of CPUs on
the instance so if you want to follow
along it would help to sign up for a
notable subscription uh we will also be
providing a requirements.txt file so you
can just install it if you want to do uh
it on local like if you want to follow
along on local the only problem is that
sometimes we'll be using spark it can be
tricky to install with Java but do you
have a I guess you have two options
number one you can use notable with us
or number two like if you don't want to
install if you want to follow locally
and you don't want to install spark you
all the code that we have can also be
run on desk or array just with a couple
of changes so you can also do that and
I'll I'll go through that more later and
then all the content for today's
tutorial is in the repo so I'll give a
quick minute uh for people who want to
follow along to copy that down
um it's a at the bottom there kvn kho
slash Pi data Seattle Fugue and I'll
give a quick minute there
foreign
anyone still copying that down you can
just raise your hand
okay we'll we'll go along
uh
okay so yeah welcome to today's tutorial
uh called the Fugue porting existing
Python and pandas code to spark Dusk and
Ray
um I'm I'm Kevin and we'll introduce
ourselves uh so I'll hand it over to
Anthony real quick everybody can you
hear me
cool I'm Anthony Holden I'm a senior
software engineer at interos and
interros is a supply chain analytics uh
company we do continuous monitoring
alerting and risk scoring for pretty
much every company that has data
available to us so hundreds of millions
of companies at interos part of what I
do is maintain the risk scoring uh
technology that we have so it's a lot of
Big Data Transformations
um which part is you'll hear more about
this later but it's part of how I found
Fugue and uh why I started using it at
interos previously I was a data engineer
at Deloitte working with some natural
language processing
yeah so and I'm Kevin uh currently I
contract for Citibank around some
distributed computing stuff uh most
recently I was an engineer at pre an
open source Community engineer at
prefect where I was responsible for uh
devrel uh developer education uh for
those of you who are not familiar with
prefect it's an open source workflow
orchestration framework and then before
uh going into more like a data science
tooling I was a data scientist myself
for a good four years
so for today's uh tutorial we're going
to be talking about Fugue and Fugue is
an open source project uh just I guess
quick uh show of hands if anyone here
has heard of fugue or seen it before I
see a couple okay that that's good oh
and uh for those of you who haven't I'm
glad you're here um so we have a few
gives an open source abstraction layer
for distributed computing
um basically what we do is uh what Fugue
does is it takes python or pandas code
and it's a way to bring it to spark desk
and Ray so we recently crossed 100 1 500
GitHub stars 1 million downloads on Pi
pipe and we are the back end of some
other notable open source projects so Pi
carrot is low code machine learning why
logs is a data validation data profiling
and stats forecast uh which who will
also be speaking in this conference is
focused on a Time series forecasting and
Fugue is currently used in companies
like Lyft and Terrors Bain so um I have
the repo here and the repo basically if
you go into well I'll show it later but
um uh just that that's divided into
several notebooks and then each notebook
will focus on that topic so this is what
the outline for today's uh tutorial will
be more on that later
and with that let's go to the notebooks
and the repo
so
over here with the repo
the for the thing to note is that we
have this notebooks folder and the
notebooks folder contains the notebooks
in sequential order you're gonna see
that there's this answers ipin notebook
and that's because in this tutorial we
have exercises for those of you who want
to follow along just very small quick
one-liner things uh just just so um it
can be interactive so we really highly
encourage audience participation also if
there's any questions during the
tutorial feel free to just raise it
interrupt us uh where we we highly
encourage it during so that you can
follow along uh so with that let's go to
notable so again we mentioned notable at
the start uh and what I'm what I'm the
first thing I'm gonna do is just to show
you guys uh we're not sponsored by
notable we just really like the platform
what what I'm gonna do and it provides a
consistent environment but what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to log in
my own notable account and I'm going to
clone that repo into notable
so
I guess I don't know if internet will
fail oh
sorry I'm on
someone else's laptop
I want to
ah
well uh let me try
okay
oh man
uh no no I think it's with my GitHub
sorry
let me try to log in with the GitHub
instead
oh no I'm sorry it's not my machine so
I'm uh
okay I'll just use I'll just use the
current account
um
okay sorry about that and what I'm gonna
do so if you first log into notable you
may not have a space so what you need to
do is you need to create a space first
so if you go to the create you can
create a space and I'm going to create a
new space called Fugue for today's
tutorial
and once we have the space what I can do
is I can create a project and the
project
I can you can clone directly from a git
repository so I'm gonna just go here and
paste this uh link since this repo is
public and we're going to put it here I
don't have a main branch it's called
master so you just have to change this
real quick and then you can click clone
and then we can up it's uploading to
notable now so once we go once it
uploads everything we have all our
notebooks a notable and we can just run
run them on notable
this will just take a minute
and again just for today specifically
notable has given us uh if you if you
demo it today normally you're limited to
like uh one CPU machines but for today's
demo we asked them to give everyone uh
eight CPU machines uh for so we that we
can demo some parallelization and
distributed stuff
oh uh it did not
yeah yeah
oh okay uh
yeah if this doesn't work I'm just gonna
and I guess if for people who are
following along if you have difficulty
then we'll just default to local uh and
I already did this step before so we'll
just open it if there's difficulties
with this
okay so this um I think this is just a
might I don't know if it's a internet
thing or something
but I guess I guess with that anyway
it's a good time to ask like how many
people here
um have worked with spark desk already
before
Spark
interested in race were you at the ray
tutorial this morning
part of it uh how about other people
spark that's great
okay okay I see I don't know a good
twenty thirty percent and I guess the
rest um
are you I guess Panda okay pandas what's
the usage of pandas in this room okay
much more like 80 90 okay
um since this is not working I'm just
gonna open it
um on uh
on two okay
okay
um this won't be the most up-to-date uh
so again if you want to do it on local
and notable is not working for you just
install the requirements.txt and I'm
going to be opening the notebooks here
um
so uh first we'll we'll talk about uh
just for those of you who haven't uh had
experience with spark desk and Ray we're
just gonna talk about distributed
computing first if you want to follow
along you need to
um get this
um
sorry
oh I'll zoom in in a bit you have to get
this command um over I'll zoom in
oh no it's not I need to just close this
comments tab
okay so
um before
um before I go further I just wanna
um make a python cell over here and this
these two commands are if you're
following along number one the first one
will install Java so that we can use
spark and number two the second one will
install the requirements.txt file so I'm
just going to run that real quick and
then later on we'll uh that will take
effect the second thing you need to do
is in the hardware
um we have a we like today because they
granted us this eight CPU machine we
should all choose the extra large just
so we can run things in parallel and
we'll need to do this at the start of
every notebook
um because uh the they require both the
requirements and the hardware are using
the default for every notebook so we
need to do this so now that that's
running we're going to do an intro to
distributed computing first and I guess
the first question is when do we need
distributed computing or when do we need
to scale Beyond a single machine right
and I think it's getting more and more
commonly known that uh pandas can be a
bottleneck because it was designed in a
time that where data wasn't as big so
for those of you who are not aware um
the recommended
um like for the recommendation for
pandas is that if you have let's say a
three gig data set ideally for Optimal
Performance you want 55x the amount of
ram so you want 15 gigs right so if you
have a 10 gig data set and you have a 16
gig machine you're going to start to see
some slowdowns especially because pandas
is not efficient with utilizing memory
it's not good at it also creates a lot
of intermediate copies of data so once
you start to hit this bottleneck then
you can go to start to explore
Frameworks such as spark or dusk or Ray
and what these uh Frameworks do is they
allow you to if you're using on a local
machine they let you use all the
processes of that local machine if you
are use and then if you need to use
multiple machines these Frameworks also
connect those and use allow you to use
those collectively and that's what we
call distributed computing
um so here the dusk The Dusk machine
learning documentation has a good
diagram of the types of problems we have
um I'll just
make this smaller so it fits in the
screen so
basically on the X on the x-axis is your
data size and on the y-axis is here
let's say in this case model size
because it was the machine learning
documentation but really it uh it
basically it can be any expensive
process so if your data doesn't fit in
your one machine anymore then you are
memory bound you need to look for
another solution if you're trying to do
something like maybe train 10 machine
learning models each one takes 30
minutes collectively it takes five hours
and you want to reduce that time down
then you can also explore distributed
computing as a means to spread out that
compute and then just collect the
results later so if you run into any of
these two situations then you uh it you
can definitely benefit from distributed
computing I just want to check my
installation
my library installation
oh I didn't run it
and then
the
this the images just don't render on
notable
they render a bit differently so I just
need to change so and then
um
now uh so now that you know that and of
course if you are in this section where
everything just fits in Ram it's not
taking too long then you can probably
avoid using distributed computing it
just adds unnecessary complexity
now there have been there there's there
was a popular article very recently by
mother duck saying that big data is dead
um have who saw that article about Big
Data being dead Okay quite a couple
people and basically what they argue is
that uh well they argue many things but
they argue number one people don't have
a lot of data to begin with and number
two they say that
um with the evolution of uh tools on the
local setting the need for distributed
computing is reduced right so we have
tools such on the left side polars on
the right side of DB and polars is
written in Rust wants to be a pandas
replacement as a data de facto data I
mean as a data frame Library polars
automatically uses all cores of your
machine it has strong streaming
capabilities so uh if you have a data
set that's let's say 50 gig you can just
process uh you know uh like using
windowing and you you just stream that
data in and you can scale a lot more
operations on a single machine the be a
SQL base written in C plus plus same
thing it has like predicate push down to
I mean like it can it can optimize your
operations uh something that pandas
doesn't do is it doesn't have an
inherent Optimizer but like duckdb with
SQL can use like a SQL based Optimizer
so you can more effectively deal with
larger data sets so these two what's
nice about them is that let's say you
only have eight gig of RAM you can still
sometimes process you know 16 I mean
like 12 gig data set 16 gig data sets it
can still handle that because of the
streaming nature and because of the
optimizations so but but we we think
that even though these local tools are
are there already there's still a lot of
room for distributed computing if you
don't have memory Bond problems you will
still likely have compute Bond problems
or you should think about potentially
leveraging distributed computing for
compute bound things right a week uh the
the the success of our machine learning
or data science work is it's based on
it's really hinged upon the number of
upper iterations we can do and using
distributed computing can really
increase your uh iteration velocity and
help you arrive at a solution faster
so what does distributed computing look
like so the top the top this is a a
diagram taken from the Das issue so on
the top is the client side uh and on the
bottom is the cluster so the cluster
consists of scheduler and workers uh and
basic basically your client will put in
a request to the cluster and the
scheduler will be responsible for
Distributing that work across the
cluster uh in practice you don't have to
work with like these individual
components for example if you have a
spark data frame and you're doing
operations on the spark data frame this
is already happening for you under the
hood so you you this is just um more of
understanding what what the system looks
like underneath
and the the thing that we need to know
for um especially as we go into
distributed computing is that inside
each worker each worker will hold a
chunk of data so if your data doesn't
fit in one machine it's going to chunk
up that data and each worker or holds
part of your data and those parts of
your data are called partitions so if
you think of desk the Das data frame uh
is just a collection of pandas data
frames and it's just you know split uh
these uh it's just several pandas data
frames split in a certain way like with
some grouping logic so over here maybe
this worker May hold for the pandas data
frames and this worker May hold another
four pandas data frames and collectively
you have 12 right
uh and the reason we we bring this up is
because later on we'll we'll talk about
how we can utilize partitioning
effectively for uh
when we bring our Python and pandas code
to spark desk and Ray and this uh
I'll just make this image render
and so what does the current distributed
computing ecosystem look like we have
three main players right now spark Dusk
and Ray uh spark would definitely be the
most uh popular so right today of the
three and I would say each of them has
pros and cons we don't really need to go
into them because in practice if your
organization is already using like one
of them then you're just likely to stick
with it it's very rare to mix and match
although we believe that the in the
future we will see more mixing and
matching of these Frameworks for example
spark is really strong in pre-processing
and we think Rey is really strong in
machine learning so we think that in the
future you may see use cases where you
pre-process and Spark and then you start
to do your machine learning portion in
rape but uh as of today it's mostly
common that you'll just be using one of
the three there was also the ray
tutorial last uh just just before this
at 9 00 am and there will be a desktop
also in this Pi data Seattle but what
are the so we talked about the need for
distributed computing but what are the
pain points is moving to distributed
computing like what do actually what do
people actually if it's like if it's so
easy everyone would be doing it and why
aren't people doing it right and the the
there are a couple of reasons for this
number one is that when you're using a
cluster your iteration cycle drama
drastically slows down it becomes more
expensive both in developer time and in
compute resources number two the code
can be harder to test uh and you'll see
a good example of this uh in the sense
that now sometimes in order to test my
code I need to spin up the uh some
resources or a cluster just so I can
test so now even if I'm just doing a
small like test like I want to test a
small piece of business logic all of a
sudden I have to spin up a cluster and
that can be very cumbersome to do and
then uh there's a lot of of course
debugging it's harder to debug and
that's why if you don't need distributed
computing you're best sticking on one
machine but we're here to simplify that
experience and we're here to say that uh
uh you with very with very like just
very minimal incremental knowledge you
can leverage these distributed systems
uh properly
so here's an example of like let's say
so in Us in some organizations what they
do is they kind of um uh have their data
scientists iterating in pandas on a
smaller data set and when it's ready for
production they hand it over to some
kind of machine learning engineer
Persona who then is responsible for
converting that code to spark and then
productionizing that code so that way
the data scientists don't have to learn
these distributed computing Frameworks
but let's take a look at a quick example
of how a certain operation can have
different results across the two
different backends so here I'm just
creating a data frame just random data
100 items sorry 50 items random in
between 1 and 100 and we have two groups
A and B and I'm gonna do a group by
median so in pandas it's very simple
it's just grouped by median and I can
just execute this and I see I need to
make this bigger for you and now I can
see the results I get this 55.5 47.5 and
in pi spark we have a slightly different
expression right so this is now native
spark code and in order to do a group by
median this is my median call and you're
gonna see that it's uh it's a percentile
and on on a column I'm getting the 50
else I'm getting the median and there's
this number 10 and this well does anyone
know what the number 10 is or represents
ah okay okay I I'm kind of blind I can't
really see I don't I don't have my
glasses but so the number 10 is a
tolerance right and this is um and what
you're gonna see is that when we run
this we actually get different results
we get 43 and 45 compared to earlier the
panda solution this one is 55 and the
reason for that is because in spark uh
there's a tolerance so we don't have to
get the exact median and that's because
it's computationally expensive to get
the median when your data is spread
across multiple machines so for example
if I have 10 numbers and Anthony has 10
numbers and we need to get the mean of
of of my set and his the mean of our
Collective set then I can just get the
mean of mindset I can get the mean of
his set we can combine it no problem but
if he has 10 numbers and I have 10
numbers and we need to get the median we
need to exchange information in some way
and that's why it becomes
computationally expensive there's no way
I can just aggregate a single
representative value and then have him
aggregate a single representative value
and then successfully get the median and
that's why there is this tolerance so
even even if you're doing the same
operation there are still considerations
when you move to the distributed
computing system them and we'll see more
of these later
the second thing is that even if you
have here what I'm doing is I'm just
changing a to Apple and B to banana and
I have a dictionary that does that in
pandas you just assign and you do a
replace operation no problem but what
does this operation look like in spark
in spark I have to create this map this
is a spy spark function I have to create
the map and then uh I I need to uh this
I mean this is still Native python but
basically I have to use the the lip the
lid is a pi spark construct map is a pi
spark construct and now I inject a lot
of Pi spark code into my logic right and
Pi spark I need to code in pi spark and
it's quite invasive and the reason that
this is problematic is because now as a
data scientist when I'm starting a new
project I have to think do I uh start
this project in pandas or did I start
this project in spark and it it can it
can be uh problematic one way or another
you start it in pandas but you realize
your data is too big now you have to
convert it to spark on the other hand if
I if I do everything in spark maybe it's
it's used like using a very like a
sledgehammer for a nail right it's it's
too much maintenance and computation
that I need for for a relatively small
problem and the reason is that we can't
really because of the uh because the
code is expressed in a way that's tied
to the framework we can't just mix and
match I mean we can't just like swap
easily and that's why we on the Fugue
side are uh want people to be able to
express their logic in python or pandas
and then bring it to spark without
worrying about rewrites without worrying
about the spark uh constructs or native
code we want people to code as much as
possible on the local machine
and then bring it over when they're
ready
and with that we'll we so we want to
create this abstraction layer that lets
us toggle engines easily and with that
we'll go to the note the next notebook
which is an introduction to fugue
so again if you want to follow along
I'll paste this uh
I'll paste this command it's also
present in the readme you can run it I
don't know that I'll be running code of
myself so maybe maybe we don't need
oh yeah and then again Hardware you can
go extra large
for today thanks to notable but we're
not sponsored we're just friends uh so
now we now an introduction to Fugue so
if you get some open source project that
aims to simplify distributed computing
so a while ago I mentioned that the
three main players are spark Dusk and
Ray
oh sorry I have to run it because I have
to run the first cell because I changed
the hardware
so now fugues what Fugue does is it's an
interface that lets you use Python
pandas or SQL any SQL lovers here or SQL
as a first language over pandas all
right that's good to know
um you know we a lot of data scientists
are kind of allergic to SQL like they
think that like it's inferior in some
way that it can't express a lot of
scientific Computing operations but we
think that actually we can leverage uh
SQL very nicely with python and we'll
see a bit of that in this notebook so a
few takes python pandas and SQL code and
brings it to spark desk and Ray so few
gives that intermediate layer uh and
then this on the right side just so if
you're not as familiar with the
distributed computing ecosystem oops
sorry these are the easiest ways to spin
up clusters so if you're using spark you
get data bricks dust coiled array any
scale
Etc
uh so now what are the core ideas behind
fig number one we want to bring the
iteration as much as possible to to your
to your laptop to like a single machine
as native as possible we don't want you
to be coding in spark or in thus us much
as much as possible so that you can keep
your code free of dependency from these
Frameworks and then we want users to
also be able to like like a while ago I
asked how many people you spend this and
around 80 of this room raised their hand
conversely with spark around like I
don't know 20 30 raise their hand and
the pro and in the industry we see that
a lot of more people are comfortable
expressing their their business logic in
pandas or in pyth Native Python and we
want people to be able to leverage that
uh while while uh and still leverage
distributed computing we we don't we
want to decouple the logic and execution
which will be in the next uh notebook
so just quick questions that we get
number one how is field different from
like there are these like uh pandas
drop-in Replacements uh modern and uh
koalas or pandas API on Pi spark what
they what they recommend is you just
change the import statement and
everything just works everything goes to
the distributed setting and we think
that um on the Fugue side we think that
that's too magical and we think that if
we invest just a little bit more to
learn uh just the distributed computing
Concepts not even code just Concepts
then we can leverage the system much
better so for example Panda and we think
that pandas itself is not optimal as a
grammar for distributed computing right
so pandas has a lot of assumptions that
all the data resides on a single machine
and pandas is heavily reliant on the
index right so when you do a group by
you reset index you set index there's
multi-index Etc and on the other hand
spark has no index spark is more is
closer to the SQL semantic why is that
right and the reason for this is because
the index is an implicit ordering or
bookkeeping that adds a lot of overhead
which is fine on a single machine but
when it extends to uh to distributed
computing
now we have to sort the data across
multiple machines just to keep that
concept of an index and in a lot of
cases we don't even need it and that's
why SQL is a very natural fit for
distributed computing because it doesn't
uh it doesn't assume ordering of data
across multiple machines and then number
two let's think about desk right because
dusk is supposedly let's get pandas and
let's make it distributed but if you
think of dusk that's actually in terms
of matching the pandas API they only
match 45 percent of the pandas API why
is that because they actually explicitly
made a design decision to only carry
over the operations that make sense in
undistributed cons system so for example
you can't do stuff I don't think you can
do stuff like transpose because
transpose is a very expensive when your
data spread across multiple machines you
can't do stuff like multi-index because
again if an index is a sort on one
column A multi-index is a sort on two
columns which can be expensive and you
may not necessarily needed
second we get asked how we're different
so on Fugue we are not we we fully
believe in pandas as a good grammar for
local computation
inside the worker but we don't think it
should be the grammar that spreads the
work across the workers
number two we get asked about uh Ibis um
anyone familiar with Ibis I might just
skip this if no one oh okay one person's
familiar with Ibis uh so Ibis is just a
kind of like a python interface on top
of SQL Alchemy it's also kind of a
bridge between like you can have one
code and then you can say run this on
databricks run this on pandas the
difference between us and Ibis is that
we really highly value consistency in
order for uh the abstraction layer to be
able to let users iterate on the local
setting and bring it to spark desk array
later that means that they need to have
consistent results so that they so that
what they do on the local matches what
they do in the distributed computing
system so we heavily invest in
consistency and consistency is actually
quite a challenge when you when you do
such a project like for example when you
this is the default Behavior you can add
code to uh change it but this is the
default behavior when you're on pandas
null joins with null and non-spark null
records are actually not joined with
null and then in group by Arnold's
dropped from the group by or are they
kept in the group by so on the Fugue
side we actually add a lot of extra code
to keep these consistent to keep the
consistency and we're consistent with
spark rather than pandas so that
whatever you do on the local setting
translates well to the distributed
setting so what does Fugue look like
first look at Fugue I'll try to increase
the size so here
this is where we start now uh so now now
what we want because we what what I'm
going to show you is just the initial
code what does it look like if I want to
bring code from the local setting to the
distributed setting uh so here we have
this first uh uh this first cell is all
Native I mean pandas right I'm just
making a linear regression function uh
with scikit learn this is my function
over here I'm just getting that model
making a new column called predicted
runningmodel.predict and this is just a
regular uh pandas function right and uh
just a quick notable plug here you get
like for a data frame you get these
distributions and you get a lot of these
plots and information that you can
explore
so next let's say let's say this uh this
this python function how do we bring
this to spark or task array so let's say
we train the model on small data but we
have big data we need to run this on how
do we actually do that so and that's
where a few comes in so fugue's most
minimal interface is this transform
function and the transform function is
just one single uh function call that we
find can actually uh you know address a
lot of use cases already so here
I'm just using the transform call and
I'm using the input data frame this is
my predict function I have to specify an
output schema because a schema is an
explicit requirement in spark and I'll
show you the spark version of this later
and then what are the parameters into
that function and then I can just run
this
and this is just running still all on
pandas and now in order to bring this to
spark what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to make a spark session and this
is the session that would connect to
your cluster if you're not familiar with
spark and all I have to do is pass in
that session so all I have to say engine
equal to spark this is exactly the same
transform call and if I
um the the so so the Sparks this is
running on local but the spark session
for those who are not familiar will take
a good 20-30 seconds which is what which
is why uh running like did running the
distributed computing on Frameworks uh
the distributed committing Frameworks on
your local system is not friendly for
iteration and then here we do we print
the type of the result you're gonna see
that it actually gives us a sparked data
frame now a native Pi spark data frame
and we can do result.show to show what
that output looks like so just by adding
this engine equal spark we're now able
to bring that python based function to
spark and if we wanted to use dusk you
can also do stuff like this
engine equals desk is also valid or you
can pass in your desk client and if you
want to use Ray it's the same thing you
can say engine equals array so for those
of you want to follow along but don't
want to install spark you can just use
task array also
um
now moving on
uh and what would it look like let's say
if you didn't exist how would we get
that python function without any edits
and let's bring it to spy spark and with
pi with pi spark we have to create these
two helper functions these typins are
also required and we had when I told you
schema is required we have to Define it
with the spark schema and this is an
injection of spark dependency already
right like this run predict
automatically has spark code in it
already whereas a while ago in that
transform call we had no spark construct
and now what have what you can run this
helper function it returns a pi spark
data frame and you can do result.show
but the problem is that we in order to
just keep our logic in Native python we
are penalized because we have to write
two helper functions now and if you want
extensive unit test coverage that also
means you have the unit test these two
functions uh these two functions and
then the second thing is that
um there there is a lot of interplay
between the distributed components
versus your business logic and then a
lot of times it can be harder to
maintain
um I'm just going to do a quick peek at
Fugue SQL before we move on Just for
those of you who are interested in SQL
so uh notable has a native integration
with SQL so we have the highlighting
which is why we're using notable today
but basically uh we also have a SQL
interface that's one to one with the
python interface you can just run
everything like that uh this is just
running SQL on top of pandas and then we
also try to one of the problems with SQL
is that it's not it's a second class
citizen so often you'll have python code
SQL code python code and we want to
elevate SQL as the first class driver so
it can execute end-to-end workflows so
instead we have the capability for SQL
to invoke python functions so here I
have a python function I'm going to edit
it a bit and now I can use the transform
keyword in my SQL
and I can say select from this input
data frame transform and now we invoke
that python function so SQL can be your
main driver
and then if you want to productionize we
have this function you just wrap it in
the string this will work and then if uh
I also if you want to run this on spark
you just say engine equals spark again
past the spark session if you don't pass
in an engine it'll just run on pandas
and then same thing you can say engine
is desk engine is Ray Etc and the last
thing I'm going to show is that we can
actually do stuff like plotting also
with python Integrations we can say
select from this input data frame
transform and then output using this
line plot and with that I'll hand it
over to Anthony for the next section
where we dive more into the transform
function
oh and questions are also very much
welcome
cool hi again I'm Anthony so
when first interacting with Fugue we're
going to talk about type hints which is
part of the way uh the logic and the
execution get decoupled in Fugue so
first though I'm going to run that code
and switch my Hardware
oh it's markdown then we'll do
then
size here we go
run yeah
cool
all right now that we've got the
installation running
we can
start talking about uh the way we the
way your mindset is when you're working
with Feud versus working with uh a
framework a specific implementation so
uh this with the the things that I'm
about to present aren't just kind of
things in abstract right these are these
are the things that I experienced when
uh uh adenteros I was tasked with taking
uh you know not just a few lines of
business logic but hundreds of lines of
complex business logic related to how to
calculate the Cyber risk score for a
company and distribute it across
hundreds of millions of companies that
in Terrorist tracks and monitors
so uh
the questions that I was trying to
answer in in that process right was uh
okay how long will it take for me to do
this how long will it take for me to
learn all of the pi spark equivalents of
all of the pandas uh expressed uh
functions and
um uh how will the original developer be
able to know that my Pi spark
implementations are creating the same
results that the original data
scientists is expecting given that they
only know pandas they don't know Pi
Spark
so one way to um
let me try running that again
um
the benefit of you then comes in where
we're decoupling the logic from the
execution instead of approaching the
problem with the initial decision of the
framework that you're going to use
instead you get to think in a more
clearly and more free way about the
computational problem that you're trying
to solve and the benefit of this is is
pretty significant in terms of uh
development experience and in terms of
time to development so you reduce the
amount of boilerplate code you have to
rate so for example like how many does
anybody know how to convert a pandas
data frame to a spark data frame here
yeah and if you don't how long is it
going to take you to look that up and
figure out you know how that works test
it implement it write the unit write the
unit test for it right it's a
challenging thing
um and you have to essentially do that
for every piece of business logic that
you're required to uh distribute right
so with you you don't have to worry
about that you can express it
um uh how is however is most uh
intuitive for you Fugue is not it
doesn't you know the philosophy of Fugue
isn't that you should always Implement
things in Native python you should
always Implement things in pandas you
can even write Pi spark code and um if
that's your Forte and bring it to other
um uh distribute
distributed uh uh compute providers
and so there's this interoperability
that is provided by the type pins so
let's see if um
my environment is
execution requested okay
um so there's sorry you don't have a run
time
um yes I would say just go over the code
because Iran time is not coming up okay
we're having issues with the runtime but
um so there's
so the
like there's not a straightforward
answer to how do I write my functions
for Fugue well uh you're working with
data frames in this environment right so
there's different ways of expressing
data frames in Python
um and we can we'll start with uh with a
with a natural language example here we
have a data frame of tweets
um and the the Tweet data as you see it
here is kind of a data frame in a way
right it's a a a dictionary that has a
column tweets and a list of the tweets
and we can um uh build a pandas data
frame with that data
um and you know one of the common things
that we might want to do with natural
language data is use the nltk library to
pre-process that data and
so we might want to write a function
that cleans the tweets like this so
using you know some some basic stuff
like tokenizing removing stop words and
limitizing the tweets so here the
function just goes through an individual
tweet and accomplishes the
pre-processing that we want
so when applying that to your data frame
maybe the first thing that comes to mind
especially given that we have a lot of
people here familiar with pandas is that
you know we could write a function that
takes a pandas data frame and Returns
the pandas data frame out
and that works with Fugue you'll be able
to take that function and bring it to a
distributed environment with the few
transform function with very little lift
but there's more freedom than that with
Fugue especially if you're looking for a
more intuitive way to express business
logic as business logic becomes more
complex or as you discover perhaps
limitations with the framework that
you're most familiar with so
um
here we're showing some different ways
that you could potentially write
um this pre-processing function so we
have three different ways one pandas in
pandas out right and we're going to
assign to
um uh the clean tweet to a new column
and then we can also kind of think of it
more natively if we'd like
using the type pins here where it's a
list of dict string and any type so
if that is kind of like but it doesn't
say the word data frame anywhere that's
okay that's like Fugue understands that
that shape of data a list of disks or
any is a data frame
um and that allows you to not even
inject any sort of framework dependency
and just use native python to
instantiate nltk iterate through the
rows in the data frame and clean the
tweets so for like python purists or
something or if you have a manager who's
like really hates dependencies this is
this is um this maybe you maybe wrote
the function this way but you can really
mix and match as you need you can have a
native type in and a panish data frame
out you could have kind of any
combination of these supported data
frame Frameworks
um to achieve the goals that you're
looking for in your business logic
so um in all of these functions you know
we haven't even got taken these to few
yet these are just these all work on
their own
um the question is you know okay what do
I need to do to make these functions
work
um in a distributed way
and
um this is the output of the different
um
uh functions and you'll note that
because there's different data types
involved you're going to have to uh kind
of manipulate a little bit the output of
these functions to generate the same
results so here
pre-processed tweets is able to this is
the original pandas and pandas out
function we get a pandas data frame out
with the column of the input tweets and
the clean tweets based on the
pre-processing
the second one since where was the
generator we're going to have to wrap it
in the list function and uh we'll get a
list of dictionaries just like that
function produced
and then also
um in the this one here we can uh
look at the the it was it was list in
pandas data frame out and so here we see
we get that pandas data frame as well
but we we just have to
um
uh
do different things to the input object
and output object to get to get the
result that we're looking for
um and that's uh where the amount of
boilerplate code and kind of uh uh
like maintainability question is
answered by Fugue because Fugue knows
how to deal with the different data
types because of the way it reads in
those type pins so
um regardless of which pre-processing
function we went with and again you
might have ended up with any one of
those if you were developing the code or
maybe you were handed that code from
somebody and uh you just you're just
tasked with Distributing it
Fuchs just Fuchs transform function
allows you to uh not worry about the
input and output data types and instead
just think about the logic that's
happening so
here and we'll talk about this schema
argument in the next notebook we're
showing you that we can transform the
data frame tweets
with the function pre-processed text and
we're also providing the the schema
again which we'll cover in a moment and
um I would be running this but I'm not
connected to
um the runtime unfortunately
um but uh as you can see we we get the
type out that we expect
um and we didn't have to we didn't have
to do any of the kind of uh hand holding
involved with um uh the like in this
example right where we had to deal with
the fact that it was a generator right
and and cast this list
um and uh we can also uh just change the
engine that's running in order to bring
those that few transform to a
distributed setting these previous
examples without providing an engine
it's just running on your local machine
um or is is not running
um in a
distributed away yet if we give it the
task client to run
um we'll be able to take any of those
functions simply provide it the the
client that it'll be using and transform
the data frame with the function and
receive the data out that we wanted so
you don't have to you know you don't
have to start thinking about the um
the actual implementation of the
distribution logic you just can think
about the business logic of the function
as it is and let Fugue do the
translation to the distributed framework
that you're working with
um
and
the
because you're not adopting Fugue
um uh
anywhere outside of uh you don't you
don't have to adopt Feud anywhere be
outside of where you immediately need it
so for example let's say that the only
part of our natural language program
that we needed distributed processing
for was that pre-processing step well
you don't have to write any other Fugue
code other than that tran then putting
that function into the few transform
function to achieve the results that
you're looking for you don't have to
refactor your entire program in fact
this is uh how it worked for me at
interros we have some data sets if you
think back to or we have some data
problems when you think back to that
kind of grid Pro grid image from Dash
that we showed earlier where things fit
in memory and for those operations we we
keep things in pandas we never you know
we're not going to approach the problem
of distributed computing and
as we evolve our models and we acquire
more data we
end up with the need for uh distributed
processing and so uh in around November
um uh I was able to uh
bring Fugue into our risk scoring
technology only where I needed it I
didn't have to refactor the entire thing
I didn't have to write one line of Pi
spark code to get it to work with on our
databricks clusters and the code is
still readable to anybody who
understands pandas and to people who
understand python
um
so
that's that's a big difference when you
think about you know when you when
you're approaching the the data problem
that you have the computational problem
that you have as opposed to prior to
really learning about a few I was
expecting to have to learn Pi spark
backwards and forwards in order to meet
the processing requirements that we
needed for our models
um
so that's that's uh that's how I would
characterize the incremental adoption of
Fugue and
here we are showing an example of how we
can you know even use uh maybe maybe
you're using desk
um already well you can still use
um a few to take a function that wasn't
written with desk and put it as part of
your existing spark desk or a pipeline
so maybe you're maybe you know you just
want to try it out in some place where
you're you have a function that's not
easily expressible or you don't want to
invest in rewriting it refactoring it
for your engine then you can
you can just you can bring in Fugue as
much or as little as you need to achieve
the results that you want
um and I've talked about this a little
bit but the the one use case that we'll
be looking at in this notebook around
tight pins is highly custom business
logic
um which is basically my bread and
butter at in Tarot so we have a number
of computational social scientists who
do extensive research and come up with
highly custom business logic to provide
risk assessments for every country in
the world every every company in the
world and every country in the world and
uh
the the benefit is when uh I'm looking
and I'm writing that logic I can keep it
as native as I want I can keep it in
pandas
um such that my unit tests are directly
testing the logic they're not testing oh
did I connect to spark and did my uh you
know spark helper functions do the right
thing it really helps scope the um the
development to the uh the problem you're
trying to solve right so in this
situation we have
um
you know a list of employees and some
information about them and we have
custom business logic that's not really
important what it is and in this case uh
we're uh you know assigning them a title
based on certain attributes and this
custom business logic uh Express right
here should be understandable to
somebody you know with minimal python
experience even or someone who's not
even a python developer whereas if you
were to write this in pi spark
um
it would be pretty uh pretty frustrating
right because you'd have to like
chaining chaining lots of dot win
methods
um and it can be really hard to follow
the logic of the code and in this case
you know on a cursory glance it's unit
testable and um it's uh elegantly
expressed right and
it's also distributable with Fugue which
is the awesome thing right so
um
uh here we have the the custom logic and
we've uh we're applying it to the data
frame again we're I'll mention schema in
the next uh notebook but here we've um
been able to assign the title based on
that logic
um
and bringing it to spark is as simple as
getting your spark session and giving
that engine to Fugue Fugue is the
interface between your logic and the
distributed
um
compute engine so you don't have to
think about how things uh
necessarily are translated interpreted
or plugged into each other and here you
can see it's the same information but
now in a spark data frame because we're
working in a spark execution environment
um and again that was like Native Native
python no no spark like I like uh Kevin
was asking a question earlier like oh do
you know how complicated this would be
to do in spark and I was like in pi
spark and I was like no I didn't have to
learn it because I I started using Fugue
right
um which which I think is super cool and
I think is really valuable to everybody
here who um is more familiar with pandas
and doesn't have that Pi spark
experience you don't have to you don't
you don't have to learn
um pie spark if you can express your
code in pandas or
um Python and then use Fugue
um
yeah so uh just just to let you guys
know uh we we do have some exercises
there and some other examples but in the
interest of time we'll just skip it and
move on if but you can definitely
revisit the repo or the notebooks later
on if you want to check those out
yeah so continuing on to um schema you
saw previously with fuse transform
function that schema is enforced and
um this is because uh there's a big
downsize to inferring schema when you're
in a distributed setting
um with uh pandas you're allowed to have
like mixed data types in one column
um and in order to understand the data
type of a column you have to look
through that entire column all of the
rows in the column to understand what
data type it is because you might have
you know a string at the end right and
then your your data type is no longer in
for that column it's object
um so uh that's why it's important and
uh we're going to go over in this
notebook the ways you can Define it with
Fugue so uh inference can be expensive
um and uh it's for the reason that I
said right so uh
we want to distribute Computing we want
to get our answers faster right that's
why we went to distributed computing in
the first place so if we want to rely on
the pandas Convention of allowing uh
inferred schema then we're going to have
penalties when it comes to execution
time to determine the data types and um
this example
um again problem with the new book but
um
we would find out that with desk that
without providing schema or in for gas
is called meta
um
that we would um actually get
a longer time for inference than five
seconds as indicated by the Sleep five
in this uh like simulated uh computation
because uh the dash data frame actually
has to infer twice
and when you're distributed you're also
going to be inferring across all
partitions so in Fugue uh
this is more about the the desk I'll
just chime in here how can you scroll up
so a while over here we see that there's
a sleep five and over here when we do
the group by apply and uh actually
execute that operation instead of the
expected five seconds it takes 10
seconds over here and it gives us this
warning error also that says hey you're
not supplying this meta information and
the reason this takes 10 seconds is
because for desk in order to infer the
schema it has to run one partition
your function in one partition and when
it runs that function it replaces all
your data with all your numeric data
with the number one and all the string
data with the the string Foo and it runs
through that uh partition to see the
output schema and then it applies that
output schema to something else so the
to to all the other upper partitions so
the reason that we have uh 10 seconds of
execution here is because five seconds
was used for inference and another five
seconds was used for the real execution
and so over here in the in the later
cell uh when we have um when we actually
Supply that scheme ahead of time
then the execution this is the only
change we did the execution time drops
to the expected five seconds because it
doesn't need that additional five
seconds for inference
right and so as a best practice Fugue
wants you requires you to provide the
schema as your transforming data frames
um
right here's what um Kevin just
mentioned
um
the the additionally there's uh by
explicitly providing schema you uh
prevent uh silent errors where floats
are being uh truncated as int um because
you've made assumptions about the the
data that either you know the data
you're receiving change in the type or
you were never really sure in the first
place so
um it uh again it helps you focus in
requiring this it actually helps you
focus on the the problem you're trying
to solve and the shape of your data
which is important considerations as
we've shown for distributed computing
um and and for all those reasons that's
another best practice when it comes to
distributed computing or working with
with data even even generally if you
don't use distributed computing um which
is that parquet files are more
dependable than CSV because they enforce
schema
um and addition they have um uh their
smaller file size as well
so
um there's different ways to Define
schema in Fugue and honestly I've owned
I've only used one of these ways but
there's a lot of there's you know uh
different ways that you can you can
investigate and see what's what works
best for
um the your developer experience or the
things you're trying to accomplish or
maybe the length of your schema so
um the first one is defining during
runtime and so here's the data frame
that we'll be thinking about
um uh column A with two three four as
values so
um
here we're going to assign a new column
with new values and because we're
assigning a new column the schema
changes right so schema is the the data
types for all of your columns in your
data frame should have said that earlier
and a few wants to know and so
uh this the as we as we saw in the type
in section the transform takes the
schema argument which in this case is
defined during runtime and is a string
and so
here the star is indicating we're going
to have the all of the schema present in
the original input and an additional
column because of the comma space called
new and then the data type for new is an
integer
the other way is um a schema hint and
that takes the form of a comment that
Fugue actually parses and understands
similar to the the string but um uh
it doesn't need to be specified during
run time and in a way it actually
provides documentation so if you move
away from Fugue that comment will still
be there and it will just be telling you
what your schema was there's there's no
no harm no foul in that
um also
you can use a decorator and it's also
non-invasive because the function add
new call still works
even you know if you were running it
locally without using it inside of the
transform it doesn't modify that the
functionality
outside of a few contexts
and the the framework for uh schema and
Fugue is pi Arrow which is the the
implementation for this is part of one
of fugue's packages called Triad and
the the important thing to understand is
just the the ways we showed here where
um either by using a string or the
comment we're going to Define schema
we're going to label the name of the
column and the data type
um
and there's you know there's more than
just adding columns there's also
dropping columns so we we showed that
when we're adding a column we just have
to specify
um the name of the call and the data
type in addition to the the data that we
encountered
um
initially and then dropping columns we
can use the minus sign without without a
comma to indicate that here we're
dropping a column called B the other
option is to just explicitly write out
the entire schema so this uh the the
star and the kind of minus sign B is is
like shorthand for you could also write
like
uh a and comma
C int and you could you could do
whatever
um feels best in in that scenario but
since we're dropping B you could also
just say star minus B
um what do you want to do with the
exercise okay
um and so uh with that we're going to
turn it back over to Kevin do we have
any questions in the meantime
sure
yeah yeah so the question was do we
support nested's drug type in the schema
and the answer is yes actually we do
yeah any other question
uh yeah uh sorry this one in the back I
think yeah
uh so the question is do we have
document pages that have documentation
for the function do you mean like a
self-documenting based on the like
schema or do you mean like do we have
few documentation
ah yeah yeah yeah we have we have few
documentation uh online like you'll find
it we have a few tutorials pages so
everything we showed today is will also
be available in the tutorial so that's
what you're asking
and feel free to talk to me after all so
we can I can point you there there's
also um yeah so the main way that I uh
learned how to interact with few outside
of talking uh to Kevin and Han was with
the the documentation online there's a
bunch of tutorials there's also the um
the API documentation Uh Kevin will be
talking about Fugue API in a moment and
also there's a few slacks Channel
um where um Kevin and Han are super nice
and help people and help help answer
questions
um yeah we have when we go back to the
PowerPoint the ending slide will have a
link to the tutorials yeah uh we have a
question here yes
oh
great
uh no I think I understand uh the the
question the question here is um when
when we have our schema definition uh
did we consider
um potentially doing it uh inside the
typins rather than an explicit like a
separate construct for the schema inside
the Fugue API and that's the question
right yes yes uh and uh I think um so
the answer there is uh with type hints
um I think you'll see this in pi spark
also where in sometimes you have to use
like for example you're using a UDF you
need to put the types inside like your
hints also
um I think uh not for us we found that
this expression is very minimalistic
very um easy to grasp and it's also the
type pins can get pretty long whereas we
want our schema to be as compact as
possible in terms of expression
yeah and also like um I guess it would
also be tricky to like say removing a
column in a typing that would kind of be
tricky whereas we can do uh not shown
here but we also have stuff like all
columns except or like uh only this call
like stuff like that we also have those
kinds of expressions
any other questions thank you for the
question I think is there one in the
back
yeah no oh no okay okay I would add on
that um you know I was thinking earlier
we were talking about uh what if you had
you know these are these are really
small schema right like we're you know
the examples we're showing are like one
two three columns
um because
um in
uh one way to provide this schema is
or the primary way that I've I've done
it is defining it here as a schema as a
string you can just simply create that
string using python uh and manipulate
um any any sort of objects or or string
objects how you want to create the
schema that you're going to provide to
Fugue so this this doesn't need to be
like a you know like uh you know 300
character long string
um in in this line here it can be you
can
you could write your own custom logic to
kind of create the schema dynamically
um uh prior to providing it to the
transform function
so with that I'm going to if there's not
more questions
um I'm going to hand it back to Kevin
yeah so again schema we have an exercise
but in the interest of time we won't go
over it so uh Anthony
um showed uh two sections uh and one of
them was type in so how we leverage type
pins in Fugue so that was more of an
expression thing and then schema as we
showed this a best practicing and the
next section we're going to discuss
partitioning and the reason for
partitioning is this is where we start
to differ a while ago I mentioned
there's pandas droppings and
Replacements but does but pandas doesn't
have grammar around certain distributed
computing Concepts and that's why we
start to deviate away from the pandas
interface and this is one of the
strongest ones where there's no concept
of partitioning in pandas
um whereas we we have a lot of options
available in Fugue and we think that um
we already made this very minimal so
just with a bit of knowledge you can
understand how to Leverage The
distributed computing system as much as
possible so the diagrams in this note
oh okay yeah
um yeah I'll we'll see if uh we can run
stuff um so I'll just uh see but we may
not have time but I'll just uh run this
anyhow
um okay
so with partitioning uh there's this
good blog about partitions and we took
some uh pictures from that blog so it's
linked here uh and you'll see these
pictures so
first of all when we talk about
partitioning we have to realize that
your full data lives may be too big to
fit on a single machine right so what
happens is that you're gonna break up
this data frame and you're gonna put a
part of it in each worker
but what happens is that in a lot of
cases some workers may have too much
data in comparison to the others so it's
in our interest to make sure that in
some it depends on the use case but
normally if you have very big data it
will kind of balance out anyway but
we'll see that there are scenarios for
smaller data where you may easily run
into the scenario for example you have
10 jobs and you have 10 machines it's so
easy that one of those machines ends up
with two jobs and another uh another
machine ends up with zero jobs because
of the default mechanisms for
partitioning in spark I I guess uh we
have issues here but we'll uh oh no no
no it it says processing I think we're
fine
um so moving on so let's talk about
partitioning in general and Fugue so a
while ago we showed the transform
function and there was some kind of
magic there right like what does the
transform function actually do so the
transform function is applied on each
partition uh just just to be clear so
here we have a partitioning example so
we have a data frame and the important
part is like we have this date column uh
we have a group and then we have a value
and we want to do like a group by diff
operation and what we're going to find
is that uh so this is this is the diff
uh nothing special and when we do our
default transform with this diff you're
gonna see that the first partition
there's an Nan and that makes sense
right because the first item in each
group doesn't have a diff so it's n a n
but why is the first item in B uh how
why does it have a value over Nan and
that's because we uh it got the diff
from the previous group right so what we
have to do is we have to specify using
Fugue to run this function this diff
function
this it's intended to run for one group
and on the Fugue level we have to say uh
this is this is the grouping of my data
right and how do we do this in Fugue
it's very minimal all you have to do is
say Partition by ID
and this is basically saying like group
by the group by ID diff but the the
difference is that the partition
transforms semantic it's much more
scalable and much more applicable to the
distributed setting so now we actually
this partitioning says that hey every if
if there's a like all the values of a
certain ID must be on the same machine
and all the values of a different ID
they have to be on this other machine so
it's much more uh explicit and extends
the physical distribution of the data
across your across your cluster
so over here once we provide this
partition
now we can see we get the Nan as
expected so when we when we say when we
do something like this where you say
partition
and then for example you do engine
equals array right when you do this
um it will create the part it will
create those uh partitions uh based and
each partition will have one ID inside
and then the next uh thing we need to do
is pre-sort a while ago when we did the
diff there are we we assumed The
Ordering of the time series but actually
when when data is shuffled across the
cluster and when it arrives to the
workers there's no guarantee that it's
arriving in the correct order because
spark doesn't have a concept of an order
again there's no index so for for Fugue
what we do is we expose this pre-sort so
when your data is moving around when it
gets into the partition it's already
sorted guaranteed and what we do is so
here we say we're partitioning by the ID
pre-sort by date ascending and we need
to do this to ensure the we get the
correct values when we move to spark or
even dusk and here so this is a very
minimal expression to say this is the
order that um that I need in my data
so now that we we have this minimal
expression this by Partition by ID
pre-sort this is pretty straightforward
the next thing we have to discuss is the
actual partitioning algorithm or
strategy behind because again I
mentioned at the start that for example
you have 100 jobs and you have 100
machines what is the guarantee that all
of the machines X have exactly one job
and the answer is there's no guarantee
by default
right and that's because of the the the
default way that spark does it which is
by hashing and then uh one like one of
those workers may be assigned two IDs
it's not the fault of spark uh and
that's a sensible default because as
your data scales for example you get
1000 partitions two thousand partitions
it will just naturally just you know
distribute relatively evenly but again
like what happens is um
what uh I think there's a plot here
somewhere of
what what happens is that if your jobs
are not um distributed evenly In This
Very extreme scenario we have one worker
that has two machines a two two
partitions and then we have another
executor number two that has one
partition and what happens is when we
run the operation we have a lot of idle
time for executor too and the reason is
is because executor one is just doing a
lot a lot more work has to finish all of
that before we collect everything right
and that's why for example if you have
10 jobs again and 10 workers and each
job may take one hour if you run into
this scenario where one worker ends up
with two jobs then instead of running in
one hour you end up running in two hours
and then in that second hour
you have nine workers that weren't
really doing anything because one worker
only one worker was functioning and
that's why it's important for us to have
a concept of Distributing the jobs
evenly so on the few level
uh
over
I'm looking for uh
look over here so on the few level we
expose different partitioning strategies
and even the even partitioning strategy
is one of few strongest features we're
in we we actually write the extra code
to guarantee that each uh that the
partitions are distributed evenly across
the workers so this is not the default
um because it's it can be slow to
enforce this guarantee and the the
computational uh like uh space is
actually pretty high
but we find that in some scenarios like
where we have small data but very
expensive compute this is very very much
worth it so one what we can do is we can
on the field level we can say hey
Partition by this uh pre-sort this and
then we make sure that hey we want the
algorithm to be even or hash or whatever
and the way to do that is again we just
add another string into our dictionary
all we have to do is say we Partition by
the ID pre-sort by the date ascending
and then we apply this uh uh this this
algorithm so we want this to be evenly
spread we'll say even and I'll show an
example of this over here so first of
all I just want to show that every all
of the partitioning strategies they they
will work for both uh local pandas and
on spark on pandas they may just not do
as much but then uh the same ex the
point is that the same expression will
work on both and if you say engine is
none or you don't Supply an engine this
will run on pandas just fine
so over here we run this with spark just
to show that hey that partitioning
strategy worked the next thing uh that
we're going to talk about is yeah this
even partitioning so the there are some
scenarios where uh we don't have a lot
of data the but the computational job is
just very high we really need to make
sure the partitioning is even so a good
example of this is machine learning so
here we're using the stats forecast
Library again they'll be presenting uh
this Pi data Seattle and what we're
doing is we're just generating four
different uh distinct time series with
their helper function and for each of
these helper functions I'm sorry for
each of these time series I'm creating a
model object that will run an auto arima
model on it and then we just say hey
forecast the next seven days so this is
just synonymous like any machine
learning model on a group of data uh but
the point is you want one machine
learning model per group of data right
and this is a very common scenario when
you have to do let's say your data
actually spreads across different
geographies and they need different uh
treatment uh they have different ranges
for acceptable values or maybe you have
like in some cases you have uh let's say
um there's a column and there's a value
of like price but price can be in two
different currencies then you need this
sort of partitioning to treat those uh
part different partitions differently
and that so machine learning we can have
one model per partition or per logical
grouping of data very easily with the
setup so here we uh if you look at this
code again similar to our previous code
it's really focused on like having just
one time series
that's that's our concern so when we're
iterating all we have to focus is just
on one time series first and then when
we're ready to scale and apply this to
all time series that's when we bring in
the full data spark uh uh full Spark
engine and then partitioned uh by each
time series
so over here what I'm going to show is
that
this is how we would run our forecast we
have our run forecast function it works
on one time series we applied on all
series and then again we have to supply
the schema that's expected and then on
the partitioning side
um
we we here we're doing Partition by
unique ID so we create four different
partitions
but the important and then of course
it's a Time series so we have to say uh
daytime ascending and then the algo we
want it to be even to guarantee that if
we have a four core machine that each
core and we're doing this in parallel
locally that each core gets one time
series to work on and that will give us
the optimal speed
so we can extend this concept even
further and this is definitely more
advanced already but if we break down
this concept into just submitting jobs
uh into into the cluster to execute what
we can do is we can use the cloud pickle
library and here what I'm doing is I'm
I'm going to actually serialize my whole
data frame so this is a function.fugal
use and I'm gonna serialize that whole
training data frame and I'm going to
serialize the function the training
function so you can serialize what you
can do is you can create I'll show what
this looks like it it looks like a
binary blob like this so I have four
rows and a very common setup with this
is you can like have data frame model
you want to use another region data
frame the model you want to use Etc and
then you can even extend more like you
want to do three models each right so
now what you can do is you can create
this kind of like a job data frame and
then this job data frame is the one that
we're going to partition and pass on to
sparked or desk array so here we have
that serialized function and then we
apply it on our uh series data and this
is what the output looks like and now
this is very clear right like we want
explicitly one row to go to one machine
right and here uh we
this is where we do it again it's just
the algo is even and Fugue does all the
extra work to guarantee correctness that
one partition is on each machine
and over here in the Run job what we're
just doing is we're getting the this is
again this will be the Fugue Transformer
uh we're only going to get one row each
so all we have to be concerned about is
getting that row loading in the data by
unpickling it and then loading in that
training function by unpickling it and
then we just apply that for that
training function on that data frame and
then return to result and actually and
then this will return all of the
forecasts across all of our time series
so for best practice
um just to be aware there's actually
something really subtle but important
here that's just a best practice for
distributed computing and that's um over
here I set n jobs equals to one over
here specifically so if you have machine
learning models or if you have any like
python process that tries to occupy all
cores of your machine
um or like like XG boost like GBM the
gradient boosted trees model the
gradient boosted three models they're
very uh strong on this like they utilize
all your cores it's very problematic if
you have two of those processes training
on the same machine because they're
unaware of each other and they both try
to occupy all of the cores so you hit
some kind of resource contention it can
be slower so it's very important when
you do this type of setup make sure that
each process is a single threaded just
confirm just confined to just one
process because anyway there is no
concept but some people think hey if I
parallelize on the spark level or on the
dash level and then I parallelize my
function even further I can get full
utilization of all my machines in
practice it doesn't really work like
that because on the first level it
already utilizes everything so there's
no further gain by doing a second stage
parallelism and in fact you can only run
into problems by doing so so actually
dusk has guards to specifically disallow
that if possible
um before we move on from partitioning I
I want to just re-express the the
concept in in for people who are less
familiar with distributed computing so
um when we say cluster another way to
like think about this like an analogous
way like imagine these are each students
these workers and imagine the cluster is
a classroom and you're the teacher and
you have four really complex long
division problems to give to equally
talented fourth graders you're not going
to you're obviously not going to give
two to one right if you have a 30 minute
class right because then it's going to
take that student twice as long
um compared to the other students and
you'll have one student just sitting
there in class not doing anything so in
this example it was about uh machines uh
calculating uh you know the results for
machine learning models or training
machine learning models uh that's a you
know the long division problem is analog
is analogous to the to the uh to the
implementation that we showed here in
the sense that it's a long-running task
that we want to ensure is distributed
evenly amongst our resources and the
classroom it's a student and uh the
problem is is you know the cluster isn't
like a classroom and the algorithm isn't
like a teacher and so it's actually
really hard to distribute things evenly
without fugue
well said um yeah so uh we're we're a
bit uh like I want to leave some time
for questions so I think uh there are
some extra notebooks here but we won't
go through them but number one we just
uh in this tutorial we really just
scratched the surface of Fugue with the
transform function there are a lot more
functions uh in few keep that allow you
to express end to end fully agnostic and
decoupled uh like workloads so you can
do like I'll just do a brief uh I'll
just show a quick uh really quickly what
it looks like uh it will look like this
where here so we have other functions
like load and save so you can do load
transform save and then now you can say
hey run this on spark or run this on
pandas run this on desk and then you can
also just you know uh combine these and
put them into functions also and then
now you can pass in the engine and this
engine will be applied for all of these
operations so this is a way to create
like purely engine agnostic functions or
purely engine agnostic workflows so
there's this notebook and then the
um we're just gonna wrap up here uh and
then I'll open the floor for more
questions so just to recap and there was
a question here about um the tutorials
there in the next slide so the repo is
available here but everything we talked
about is um when we when we want to move
Python and or plan this code to spark
Das array we want to do it in a way that
uh it enables the right mindset to
leverage distributed computing we
shouldn't have to adjust our our code or
our workflows or our process in order to
utilize the Frameworks effectively
instead Fugue believes the framework
should adjust to the users and let them
use the grammar that they want to
express their business logic and then
number two on a more practical level by
decoupling uh logic and execution we can
now iterate and test more on the local
setting pre like I was using data bricks
two jobs ago and we would always have to
debug on the cluster run on the cluster
that is very very challenging and very
very hard just because of the the way uh
the way the communication Works between
class client and cluster uh and you and
it's a lot of like Futures it's just not
of good so we want to decouple and have
be able to just iterate on our business
logic as much as possible on the local
setting and only when it's well tested
then we're ready to bring it to spark
Das array and then lastly we showed a
good framework about how few decouples
from the pandas interface uh just and if
we decouple from the pandas mindset then
we can also create a leverage
distributed computing for other use
cases that we previously weren't
considering especially around like you
know training multiple machine learning
models or around compute Bond problems
and with that uh fugis open source uh
feel free to try it out available in Pi
Pi just download it so the project repo
is there uh number two the tutorials are
that we got a question if our if we have
documentation the tutorials are the best
form of documentation uh we uh the stuff
we went over today was way more detailed
but then there's also a 10 minute guide
if you just want to check Fugue in 10
minutes view SQL in 10 minutes for those
of you are interested in SQL and then
our emails are here if you want to reach
out to us uh Anthony mine and then of
course we have a slack Channel feel free
to reach out
okay uh if there if that's it thank you
all for coming uh happy to chat if
you're new to distributed computing or
just beginning implementing stuff I'm
always happy to talk things through yeah
thank you for coming everyone thank you
[Applause]